momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello saludo a mi compañera
daniela blandones daniela bienvenida
este fin de semana se reanuda la
negociación presencial de un acuerdo
post break sheet andar es muy buenas
noches éstas se han venido llevando a
cabo en línea luego de que el equipo
comunitario permaneciera en cuarentena
por un contacto con un caso positivo de
coronavirus estamos felices de estar de
regreso en londres seguimos trabajando
con paciencia y determinación de que
seamos absolutamente claros este país
puede prosperar y prosperará enormemente
en cualquier caso que un acuerdo o no
andrés los negociadores tienen cada vez
menos tiempo después de que el reino
unido dejara la unión europea en enero
han estado buscando una nueva relación
comercial que rija desde enero de 2021
cuando venza el período de transición
las diferencias hoy son las mismas que
hace unos meses como asegurar la
competencia ajusta los mecanismos de
resolución de disputas y la pesca esta
última es crucial para francia y reino
unido quiere tener el control absoluto
de sus aguas decidir quién pesca allí y
quién no
y 2021 pero la frontera entre las dos
irlandas también ha estado en el centro
de la pelea andrés irlanda del norte
hace parte del reino unido- y siempre se
ha buscado que no haya controles
fronterizos excesivos pero si los habrá
o no solo se va a saber cuando haya un
acuerdo definitivo o cuando se acabe el
tiempo por el contrario y tengan que
someterse a las reglas de la
organización mundial del comercio
daniela esta semana varios países de
américa latina dieron a conocer sus
cifras de desempleo cuáles son estos
países y estamos hablando de brasil
méxico y chile que siguen viendo en sus
estadísticas las graves consecuencias de
la pandemia el desempleo en el gigante
latinoamericano llegó al 14,6 por ciento
en el tercer trimestre lo que se traduce
en 14,1 millones de personas sin trabajo
este es el nivel más alto registrado en
el país desde 2012 méxico ya había
reportado una tasa de desocupación del
4,7 por ciento en octubre más baja que
en meses anteriores pero más alta que
hace un año
el desempleo cayó al 11 6% en el
trimestre móvil que va desde agosto
hasta octubre
seguimos en américa latina' daniela
porque el gobierno de mexico tomó
medidas para reactivar la económica la
economía en sus fronteras decretó por
ejemplo reducir el iva el impuesto sobre
la renta y el precio de las gasolinas en
los municipios de la frontera sur con
guatemala para impulsar su economía
también acordó extender hasta 2024 la
reducción de impuestos que ya se
aplicaba en la frontera con eeuu los
estados beneficiados en la frontera sur
son chiapas tabasco campeche y quintana
roo desde enero de 2021 los 22
municipios de esta región ya no pagarán
iva del 16% sino la mitad y el impuesto
de renta bajará del 30 al 20 por ciento
y sube la atención diplomática y
comercial entre china y australia
cuéntenos desde este sábado el país
asiático impondrá aranceles de más del
200 por ciento a las importaciones de
vino australiano por supuesta
competencia desleal
estos dos países vienen de pelea hace
meses a pesar de que china es el
principal socio comercial de australia
la relación se ha deteriorado andrés por
cuestiones como la militarización del
gigante asiático o la aprobación en
australia de leyes contra la injerencia
y el espionaje extranjero china ha
respondido con aranceles a la cebada y
ahora al vino el gobierno australiano se
queja de que china subsidia la
producción de esta bebida y distorsión
en los precios mientras que beijing se
defiende escuchemos
durante algún tiempo algunas personas en
australia se han aferrado tenazmente a
su mentalidad y prejuicios ideológicos
de la guerra fría esto es lo que llevó
al fuerte declive en las relaciones
china australia y lo que nos llevó a un
estado tan difícil
daniela vamos a conocer los indicadores
económicos del día wall street del cerro
con subidas en un día de black friday
con pocos compradores los índices de
standard and poor's y nada que marcaron
un máximo histórico las bolsas europeas
subieron animadas por nueva york y
cerraron una semana de fuertes falsas y
en américa latina' muy buenos resultados
en especial en sao paulo que acumuló su
cuarta jornada consecutiva al alza y la
cifra del día los 25 mil pesos chilenos
o 30 dólares aproximadamente que
prometió el gobierno de sebastián piñera
como bono de kobe de navideño este será
repartido a 8,3 millones de ciudadanos
daniela muchas gracias por traernos la
información económica aquí en france 24
de ustedes muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos continúan con nosotros
[Música]